they're the nominees for the most
excruciating lead elements of the galaxy
inaugurations your dentists son's Bar
Mitzvah the Commonwealth Games lawn
bowling championship and the Academy
Awards and the winner is oh my goodness
it's the Oscars
oh I'm overcome with this comes as such
a surprise to no one I really despise
the Oscars
thanks Academy for dragging things out
for 14 hours with dumb Awards nobody
cares about like Best Actor or whatever
where's the most relevant award
you know the Gordon easier the Academy's
awards for scientific and technical
achievement it's not even part of the
telecast the Academy doles had out weeks
beforehand and a separate ceremony for
scientific and technical achievement in
order to take some of the sting out of
this horrendous slide the Academy always
ropes in some poor contractually
obligated aunjanue to look pretty for
the Nerds it is offensive Pixar's endcap
should get this prize in prime time this
Academy of assitant is so out of times
if they don't even have categories that
recognize some of the most important
figures in filmdom there's no award
honoring the designer of the best part
of a movie
the title sequence Saul Bass think about
that also every year for the last 22
years the Academy has rejected requests
to add a category for stunt coordination
Hong Kong legend hyun-woo peg would have
had an armload by now if I produced the
Oscars I'd eliminate all the scripted
banner and the musical numbers and use
the time safe to drill down on new
projection technologies who needs miss
song when you have a panel of experts
debating the feasibility of glasses-free
3d maybe I'll add a game show
we'll give terrific editors of Walter
Murch or Velma smooth marker footage
from some horrible film like Pluto mash
and give them an hour to chop it up into
something decent oh yeah now that would
be must-see TV brain a better animated
feature than wreck-it Ralph
no what do you think is the biggest
Oscar outrage
let me know in the comments and
subscribe to the wired Channel